this is a very important video,
some people, some dumb balls,
still think the earth is flat
mY gOD
how can you be so stupid?
LOGAN PAUL- thats right ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
disappointed..
now, let's look at this earth, okay
what shape is this?
that's right, round ¯\_(ツ)_/¯ (wow!)
well what a lot of people don't know..
is if you keep zooming in...
over here, over in canada
over in Saint Pierre and Miquelon...
over here at St. Johns
over here at Witless Bay...
*insert dubstep music*
we are getting closer :o
*dubstep intensifies*
over to Burnt Cove
over between the Gret Island and Sant Miquel
WEHAVee....
PEEPEE ISLAaaaNnDDD11111!!!!!!11
do do do dudu dodo doodoo
*clap**clap**clap**
smash a like on this video
𝓇𝒾𝑔𝒽𝓉 𝓃𝑜𝓌
if you want to visit peepee island...
cause I dunno about you guys..
I really want to go visit peepee island
what happens in peepee island?
I don't know :((
why does it have such an amazing name?
I DON'T KNOW EITHER-
this is proof, once and for all, that the Earth is round
I think- eu yes...
I wanted to explore a little bit more here today
where you can discover on this amazing planet Earth
thanks to google technology with google street view and google sattelite
there's so many different things to look at!
so many things to appreciate!
such as this new viral... clip
thanks to, in uh, New Jersey or something like that...
we have a google street view, of a man,
FaLLing DOwn thE sTaiRS!
*sly chuckle*
I shouldn't be laughing i really shouldn't!
OH NO! OH GOD I HAVEN't seen the second one..
I hope hes OKay i genuinely do.
let's see if we can find this...
uh alright let's add the little guy...
*continuous elevator music*
oh nooo...
uhohoho
jeSus ChrisT!
the blurred him out atleast..
god I hope he's okay (felix is a good man)
THE world is a wonderful place to live...
we also have this incredible clip, which i think i've shown before
a cute lil dog uwu , on another note..
just an adorable little dog, chasing over the google street view car... thing
*warrior music uwu*
come on doggo you can do it!!!!!111!
some say the dog is still chasing the google street view car till this day....!!!
to this day he
just doesn't give up does he?
EBACKEDA HUHUHU! I GOT U NOW, GOOGLE
jesus christ,,
okay here we goo...
zOOM IN...
we're in 名古屋市, Japan everyone!
OH MY GOOOD..
HOW DID THEY KNOW?!
only in Japan...
for those of you who haven't visited to japan, yes, this is how everyone walks around.
wHERE Did THey gO?
AHHHHH
hue hahahahaha
uh ahahaha
uh haHAHA
oh.. THATS SO CREEPY
go damn pigeon people..
THEY ARE EVERYWHERE.
take it back, the earth is not fl-
why does the Japanese Earth look different? okay...
explain this scientists. huh?
oh yeah, i know this one
okay, so, you look at the speed limit
GOD DAMNIT GOOGLE.
look at the speed limit, 37, this is taken by the google car btw
turn around here,
what is the speed limit?
GOD DAMNIT GOOGLE >:(
OH they blurred it those fu-
20!HAHA
OWHAT THE FREEK GOOGLE YOU BREAK THE LAW!
everyone tweet this out right now #GoogleBreakALaw
I'm crying, and i'm shaking right now...
google just confessed to this horrific crime...
*sad piano music found online*
pro tip google, if you break the law, don't film it...
take it from me... who's never done anything i-llegal
MOEVING ON
okay here's another coordinate..
alright, so you're just in a park
it's a nice day, it's a nice weather
you're in co fn, whatever that is...
you walk down the street, and BOOM :o
issa cow.
incredible :D cows exist!
*clap*
how did he get passed th-the cow?
that is the real question.
oh, thats some close up action right there ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
thank you very much google !
keep shane dawson away from th-
eh- that's not even a joke.. ◕_◕
jesus christ..
alright, see you later cows!! (ﾉ◕ヮ◕)ﾉ
you can find all kinds on google street view..
why go out side when you could just click through this
look at this people, lookin akward
they always loook at the camera, it's so creepy.
eh huHAhaha
one cool thing I actually find is that, is that could actually go underwater.
uh, in google map and like, here on island, you can go underwater :)
and there's a turtle ! (ﾉ◕ヮ◕)ﾉ
pretty e  p  i  c  ( ▀ ͜͞ʖ▀)
see, everyone looks into the camera, this is what i'm talking about
its so wEIRD!
damn, that's epic.
look at that... amazing
and we are killing it. :((
congardulations everyone.
alright, next up I have some coordinates i want to explore
where in the world are we gonna go next??  ( ͡°╭͜ʖ╮͡° )
that's right, everyone
we enter the coordinates, we enter the sattelite view
we zoom in one sattelite view, i assume it's over here
ZOOM IN GOD DAMNIT.
and there we have it.
hu he HA HA HA
a giant stuffed bunny, everyone  ¯\_(ツ)_/¯
GIANT-STUFFED-BUNNy, thank you Italy,very cool( ͡~ ͜ʖ ͡°)
we have this one, if you go to google earth, type in the coordinates, blah blah blah,
it's a man dragging a dead body to a lake! :0
huh! shocked face ( o_o)
that is so creepy
okay, we must investigate
let's enter the coordinate
there it is!!
huh... WHERE ARE THEY!?
WHERE DID THEY GO!?
the mysteries of life, we will explore this. we will dig deep
what happened to this person?
it's a wet dog... (?)
I mean, i should be happy, i shoul- eu he HAHA
I'LL TAKE IT.
Panic averted.
I mean it looks crazy...
alright, so just another, OH GOD. Chad.
the magnificent country,
IT EVEN HAS THE EYES...
MY GOD.... chad, all hail chad
the greatest country of all time..
now, if you zoom in a little bit outside of Chad,
and if you zoom in.... a little bit.... and then just go.. AND that's --- right..
and that's a mouth... isnt it
WELL whatever it lips... huehuehue
VERY facinating, the world is a magnificent place
prepare to be more facination (facinated) upcoming here.
adding some more coordinates.
BEE BO BEE BO
here we have innn... what the hell is this?
bing bam boom,
zoom time.....ZOOM TIME...
you can actually see, i think atleast, no?
SUPPOST TO BE A SHIP WRECK, GOD DAMNIT.
*akward scilence*
well, that makes it lame...
we also have this fanTASTIC picture, what the he-
I think this is in Mexico, so creepy, jesus christ.
theres also this wonderful place. such as, CHICAGO :D
hehe, idk if these are real, i just love it so much, heha
Welcome to Chicago, everyone.
where you can also find, arguably, one of greatst things on google street view
THIS DOG EVERYONE, UWU.
look at this dog, if this isn't worth smash, like, subscribe, I dunno what is.
inCREDIBLE, good boi ( ͡~ ͜ʖ ͡°)
meanwhile, is RUSSIA's google street view
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE? DOES ANYONE KNOW?
look, they're looking too, like aw s*** , they got it
aw damnit, google street car got it....
there is also the... i dunno... what this is...
I dunno what happening here, but i could only imagine, but they're fighting us...
oh my god...
they even convicted a man in Taiwan, thanks to google maps
because an unleashed dog was responsible for a neighbors bicycle accident.
jesus christ..
google maps will getchu man, big brother is watching you
but I think the most, the worst one is when- haha, just falling..
poor, nawww... look at the poor dog!!
*human falls down* oh no the poor dogs!
haHAHA
look at them!
I stumbles upon this random sequence randomly..
who just randomly goes on google street!? jesus christ..
TAKE BETTER CARE OF YOUR DOGS YOU DUMMY.
*fancy lobby music*
theres also wonderful images such as... BABY :D being born.
and naked man in- sleeping trunk
but if you go to Gothenburg, Sweden, my home town
you enter sattelite view, and you zoom in just enough on Stadium Ullevi
and you will find, that's right everyone..
represent.com/pewdiepie
T-Series may have beaten us.. so you might as well buy the 90 million club merch
because we sure as HELL aint getting to 200.. at this point
so thank you for your support, and i really really really appriciate it, see you guys tommorow
*attempt loli voice* BAI! ( ͡~ ͜ʖ ͡°)( ͡~ ͜ʖ ͡°)( ͡~ ͜ʖ ͡°)
*fancy elevator music*
WHAT!?
NO! NO DON'T LEEeeave
this game is still relevant, god damnit.